In this challenge episode
We’re going to play
on the craziest table setup
Cover a table full of
ping pong balls
and more
We have to play doubles
without losing the ball
So how do we move?
We have to...
We move like this
Yeah?
You got it?
Yeah!
Oooh!
We can do like this
Oh, yeah!
I have a feeling
something is going to happen
There’s so many different styles
available for this
Try this tactic
You look like a crab
I know!
Otto has no chance against this...
combo
Deadly combo!
That’s the game then
We made him laugh
That was the goal of the challenge
We got to go hard!
I think that’s enough
Next challenge
This is the amount of balls
you need to cover
a whole table
Start by covering the whole
surface with tape
I don’t think
I’ve never seen a yellow
ping pong table
We are ready with the balls
Miikka, you wanna peel?
World’s stickiest table
It sticks without pressing
It’s surprisingly satisfying
to place the balls in
the correct place there
Wouldn’t you agree
that this is one ballsy move
from Pongfinity?
The final ball of the puzzle
Wow!
Ready!
That took like one hour
to complete this table
I just made the calculations
2859 balls
After the video
Each and every order
from Pongfinity.store
will come with one of these balls
and it will be signed
by all three of us
We have to do an ‘Emil Stand Test’
No!
Don’t do the test!
I’ll try!
Hey!
It is...
It’s ‘Emil solid’
Don’t walk too much on there, Emil
That’s physics!
Alright, so let’s play
on the table covered with balls
That’s not promising
I think this is a game
that’s based purely on luck
90 percent luck
Otto, you are not allowed
to use this surface
Okay!
To Otto!
Yes!
It’s unpredictable I have to say
If you play on this for
a few times a week
you would never miss an edge ball
It’s a roller!
I think this is the way
you get the cleanest bounce
Snake!
Crazy side spin!
Nice!
Yes!
Good training
Reflex training and
racket handling skills
Next up we will have
many balls
on a table with many balls
Easy!
That is perfect!
You can get it!
What a save!
Change
Nice!
Go!
Good movement!
That is fun!
And guys
If you wanna get yourself
an own piece of this table
Go ahead an order anything from...
One of our wildest table setups
The goal is five (rallies)
No!
I have a feeling three shots is
quite the maximum we can get
Let’s try it out
This is a very difficult one
It looks so weird and impressive
Nooo!
We will get five
as long as we get the touch for the...
NO!
If it comes here
you just have to put more side spin
And then it corrects it
No!
For me it’s almost this
C’mon!
Four!
1-0!
Oh, no!
That’s perfect
if it doesn’t come like
out of table so much
We got...
Was it six?
That’s crazy you can actually play
on something that is sideways
It’s comical to think that
these two guys
won the Finnish championships
While all the other players
are playing the sport seriously
I think we smashed that
Next challenge
Guess the hitter
No!
Michael
Yes, Otto?
You wanna come sit here?
Yes!
Aaaah!
I’m not going to give you
any mercy after that
Miikka
I felt the revenge
No?
It wasn’t!
How?
Sorry!
Let’s stop!
It was a fun game, guys
We have five serves
And the one who gets
most points, wins
And
they are going to be very illegal
So, the first serve
Yes!
I got a good one
Easy!
Miikka takes the lead
That worked a lot better
than I expected
That was a good serve
That was too easy
No one has received
Miikka’s serve yet
I’m running out of ideas
No, it didn’t work!
Oh, you got a point
It didn’t work
It worked!
What?
So easy
They were just too good
Otto, maybe I’m just lucky here
You just have better serves
First one
to get the last piece of the puzzle
wins!
That’s good!
This is quite a bit
harder than I expected
Doesn’t matter if you
aim at the hole
No!
I can just
out it like this
And it’s
equally bad
Yeah!
That was close!
There!
We are going to need your help
Miikka,
It’s not your turn
It’s whoever’s turn
This might take two hours
This might take two days
Keep going!
Yes, thank you!
How many hours have you tried?
Six hours
We shoot the same time
C’mon!
Just somebody get it in now
Exactly!
Okay!
If you really want
C’mon!
You got it!
We just had to find
the right technique
Yeah!
Everybody together
Every single order
until 18.6.2023
Will get
a ball from this table
signed by all three of us!
So go ahead
and make your order now